There may be two ways
to receive your grades.
On the Assignments page,
once you have received your grade, this
column will be updated to say, Returned.
Click the assignment name and
you will see your grade at the top.
Then scroll down to see your feedback.
Depending on the assignment,
you might receive some attachments
associated with your feedback.
Some classes might have
the Gradebook function,
where you will see all of
your grades for the class.
Not every class uses this Gradebook.
Different classes return
grades in different ways.
Make sure to pay attention,
specifically, to how your class
will return grades to you.